I would tell kids who want to make
movies to make movies when I was a kid
the only way I can make movies was
borrow money from my father and borrow
his eight millimeter movie camera today
you can take your telephone you can make
a movie on that never went to film
school I started making films using my
dad's Super 8 camera and action figures
doing stop motion films a little bit of
Animation a certain amount of live
action and I just carried on making
films as I grew up every time I see kids
who say well how am I going to make my
movie unless I can you know get
Hollywood to pay for it it's like get an
iPad your parents don't have an iPad
like someone you know has an iPad like
go make your movie
the communal experience is always
important you can make a film on a
hammer the size of that doorknob and
still show it to 1600 people in an
audience it's still a great communal
experience to me the great hope is that
now these little eight millimeter video
recorders and stuff will come around
some just people who normally wouldn't
make movies are going to be making them
for once the so-called professionalism
about movies will be destroyed forever
you know and it'll really become an art
form